andrew doyle is an irish journalist
who's perhaps best known as the creator
of the twitter personality titania
mcgrath
a parody of an ultra woke 24 year old
that he says is a militant vegan who
thinks she's a better poet than william
shakespeare though the 43 year old doyle
describes himself as a left winger
he's a fierce critic of cancel culture
and proponent of brexit
he holds a doctorate from oxford in
early renaissance poetry
is the host of the new nightly show gb
news
and a columnist for spiked online he's
also the author of the new book
free speech and why it matters a
comprehensive
learned and compelling argument in favor
of unfettered debate
and open expression reason talked with
him about
why cancel culture is on the rise how to
combat it and what titania mcgrath is up
to
as she approaches her quarter life
crisis
andrew doyle thanks for talking a reason
thank you for having me
so free speech and why it matters what
is the
elevator pitch of the book well i
suppose it's a book that i didn't think
i would ever have to write i think the
idea
uh came to me because uh we are in a
situation at the moment where
although it's not quite crisis point uh
we are definitely detecting
uh more and more people who are willing
to
let slide the principle of free speech
which i consider to be the foundational
uh principle of our society
and um there a lot of this is a sort of
well-intentioned thing
but there are people who are moving
towards let's say more aggressive hate
speech laws
or urging further big tech censorship
or this kind of rise of what we call
council culture this kind of a strategy
of attempting to uh
to shut down certain opinions
unfashionable opinions or viewpoints or
ideas or even jokes
um and this is this the reason why i
thought the book was important was that
this is happening more often now uh you
know whereas about 15 years ago
i would we you know everyone it was just
a given everyone just agreed that free
speech was this very foundational
principle and
and and it was very important now the
rise of
this kind of free speech skepticism i
find a bit disturbing and actually the
book isn't really
aimed at the the activists who just
simply don't believe that free speech is
a good thing
um it's it's more at the majority of
people who broadly speaking believe in
in free speech but they're also nervous
about demagogues
uh saying hateful things or or the the
potential impact of language it's been a
while
since uh we've dusted off the actual
reasons for free speech i mean right
it's become a kind of blank bromide
you know in early on in the book you you
uh talk about
we are left facing that confusing and
rare phenomenon
the well-intentioned authoritarian and
you talk
at the opening of the book which is just
a fantastic kind of set piece
in a section called we need to check
your thinking you write
between 2014 and 2019 almost
120 000 non-crime hate incidents
were recorded by police forces in
england and wales
this sort of development has left a
substantial number of inquiries etc what
is
a non-crime hate incident and why are
the police
collecting such data this is a very
interesting point because recently the
home secretary here pretty patel has
said to the college of policing the
college of policing being the body
that is responsible for the training of
all police officers in the uk
um that they shouldn't be advising
police officers to record non-crime
or investigate non-crime um however they
still haven't updated their website or
change that i think you're going to see
this battle between the police the
college of policing specifically and
pretty patel
there is a culture within the uk police
that they believe it is partly their
responsibility
to investigate certain uh language uh
certain linguistic misdemeanors shall we
say and
and to ensure that people aren't being
offensive it is a cultural problem
within the police force so
a non-crime hate incident as as you say
many many thousands of which are
recorded every year
is when uh so for instance if if someone
said something mean
to me and i interpreted that as being
coming from a say a homophobic
basis or whatever i wanted to however i
wanted to interpret that
i could phone the police and say i
believe um it was my perception
uh that this was a an attack based on uh
uh my sexual orientation which is one of
the five protected characteristics
what are the other ones do you remember
them uh okay so it's race
uh gender i uh it's race gender
disability um religion
and uh i think that the last one is a
gender identity
i think uh i would have to double check
that um so
i think people you know like short
people were like well you know again we
are
just written out of the discussion uh
well exactly i mean there have been
calls for sort of why aren't vegans in
there and this kind of thing i've
actually got the list here
uh it's yes it's it's disability or
perceived disability race or perceived
race
religion or perceived religion sexual
orientation or perceived sexual
orientation
or a person who is transgender or
perceived to be transgender what you see
there though is this constant repetition
of the concept of perception
because it doesn't really matter whether
someone had um
attacked me with a homophobic motive or
not it's whether i decide
that that was their motive so it's about
that this is not
a crime but the police is keeping tabs
which you know it's a non-crime it's not
gross
the police's explanation when the police
are challenged on this the explanation
is that
uh non-crime can lead to or that crime
is always preceded by non-crime
which i would i think it's always
succeeded by donald trump
as well right i mean unless we just
cross a line and then it's just crime
all
you know for the rest of it exactly it's
it's um
yeah it's a and it's an absolute given
so so it is recorded so the police
record it sometimes they investigate
and in all cases it is recorded and the
problem with that is well firstly the
police have no business investigating
people for non-crime that's the first
thing
but the the massive principle you know
you're talking to somebody who
you have to convince me the police have
a right to invest me
and investigate me for crimes well then
well
yeah so this is way out of your league
you know you you wouldn't tolerate this
at all
but but in addition to that their their
idea that
if you you know hateful words inevitably
lead to violence it's interesting
because uh
there was an article recently talking
about the number of these
recorded non-crimes that have actually
led to crimes
is is precisely zero so even by their
own statistics they know that this is
buncombe um but they there is this
culture i mean recently we had the
police in merseyside near liverpool or
in liverpool um
standing there was a picture a
photograph that went viral and they were
standing in front of this digital
billboard
and on the billboard it said the slogan
being offensive
is an offense and this was flanked by
these
very menacing looking police officers
and of course this went viral because a
lot of critics were saying well actually
being offensive isn't against the law
and
the one of the the striking things about
i thought that
you know at least 90 percent of english
culture is being offensive
right it's important to us that's that's
how we get along um
but i think it what was interesting is
that was it it wasn't just some
sign that some rogue police officer had
sketched up and put up it was a it was a
digital billboard that obviously there'd
be meetings discussions
uh people had discussed the language
that should be so there's obviously a
culture within the police
force where they think that it is their
job to investigate people for being
offensive and the scary thing about it
is actually they had kind of
inadvertently hit upon a truth
because it is against the law to be
offensive in this country quite
explicitly the
2003 electronic communications act says
that if you post material that is
quote unquote grossly offensive that is
the uh the stipulation for
criminal prosecution so actually we are
in it
that's there's another reason why i
thought this book needed to be written
and that that phrase we need to check
your thinking which came from
a policeman who was calling up somebody
right that is
i mean you know that i mean it's one
thing if that's happening within the
context of a classroom or even a board
room but
the idea that the police would be the
agency that would be
checking your thinking is kind of
terrifying yeah because it's straight
out of all well
it's it is thought crime and um i know
that's become a cliche but what are you
going to do that's exactly what it is
yeah and it's it's interesting that it's
out of war well but it's also by way of
burgess right in clockwork orange where
the police are revealed without any
romanticism
to be you know a bunch of drugs who are
you know as violent as the criminals
they're supposedly apprehending
certainly that's where we are in america
and i mean this is an overstatement
but you know the last people you want
policing things are the police right i
think everyone should read clockwork
orange they should read
1984 and if they read the crucible as
well we'd probably be in a a much better
situation i love clockwork orange by the
way i love the way that after about 10
15 pages
your mind just adjusts to the language
it's it's really smart
it's uh you know a side note but what's
fascinating is that the version that was
published in the united states uh
left off the final chapter in which yes
spoiler alert alex is redeemed
or or grows out of it actually because
he's a young child
and um that has a radically different
you know it leaves the book with a
radically different message
well i mean it feels like then he's sort
of saying well
there is an inevitability to do a
violent impulse in male youth
right and he might be on to something
there um but but then you know
and also one that gets grown out of um i
mean there's a well i mean
we know that i mean violent crime past
the age of 40 decreases hugely we know
this so
you know there's there's something in
there so you know the idea of having the
police checking your thinking and what
you were just discussing is
is one sign that we are in a different
era when it comes to kind of
the way that we talk about the way that
we think about free speech and and
potential offense arising from you know
just kind of an open discourse
what are some of the other examples i
mean before we talk about free speech
being you know the the problems with it
being under attack can we document a
little bit more
how we know it is under attack when i
talk about um
well i've spoken about hate speech laws
i mean there's the fact that we have
that
just in terms of legislation which i
think is a major issue which you
obviously
are less likely to have given your first
amendment right although we do
have certain you know there are times
where that is but the the
types of things which uh you know are
are frankly becoming more
conceivable here but in europe as well
as in england you know the idea that
making fun of a religion or
selling nazi memorabilia is somehow
illegal
that's a bridge too far but there are
types of hate crime
you know there is hate crime legislation
which intensifies
uh criminal penalties sure uh you've
you've got that you've also got a
movement
in america from certain activists to see
that the hate speech doesn't count
within the
constitutional protections so and and
then of course you've got prince harry
coming over there and telling you
that your first amendment is yeah we
need to talk about that you know free
trade
free trade is is a fine thing but not
when we're
you know this is an import that uh i
think we really should have put a very
high tariff on
i yes i'm sure so anyway in terms of
other exams so we yes so
in the uk then specifically in the uk we
have got the public order act and the
communications act both of which encode
kind of hate speech legislation
across europe every most most major
european countries have
late hate speech legislation which
differ depending on the country a good
way to have a look at that is paul
coleman's book censored which actually
reproduces facsimiles of all of the hate
speech
legislation so you can see it for
yourself in fact the most of the book is
is is just reproductions of the of those
laws
um yes so there's there's the the legal
side
of things and then there is the cultural
side of things and and
i think it goes back to what you said
about how you know i felt that i had to
reiterate
and sort of polish up uh the the um
a trans-historical defense of free
speech which is something that we forget
and i think it is something that you
have to
kind of not take for granted because it
is so rare and because we are
because it is so miraculous that we live
in a country with free speech that we
have to just continually make the case
it's not something that you
you win and then it's going forward what
you know you you said you think free
speech is is
you know that is the basic thing like
everything comes after that
why you know just very briefly why is
free speech the starting point
and when when does it en when does that
defense of free speech for you emerge in
a kind of uh
anglo-american or western culture you
know as
okay this is the first right because
it's the
seedbed of all other liberties i don't
think you can have freedom without the
freedom
to express yourself it's why the free
speech movement at berkeley it's why
um the early civil rights activists were
all unanimous in their in their defense
of free speech because they understood
that they wouldn't be able to secure any
of those other liberties without the
freedom to say what they
thought and that seems and as we know
across the world all of the the
countries in which free speech
protections are poor
it is minorities who suffer the most so
there is a very important reason why we
we we need to defend it and particularly
the ironically i think
the people who are most antagonistic
toward the concept of free speech
uh from minority groups and minority
activists uh those are the ones who have
the most to benefit from it
so that's why i wanted to uh write a
book that they could read and would not
be feel alienated by i'm not attempting
to
i'm not insulting them i'm taking their
arguments seriously uh
and attempting to engage with them in
terms of the the cultural reason why
uh free speech defense is necessary is
because of this rise of cancer culture
which is something which is often
misunderstood
uh either because people take it very
literally and they say well no one's
been actually cancelled have they and of
course it's a metaphor
and a lot of these social justice
activists aren't particularly adept at
metaphor
what we mean by this is a kind of a
system or a
a a strategy or an impulse
to uh to publicly shame someone
to harass and threaten someone or to
contact their employer
defame their reputation to such an
extent that actually their livelihood is
is damaged and and possibly destroyed
uh so it is a a essentially vengeful
uh approach to disagreement that's what
so it's
kind of the hecklers veto uh you know
writ large right as as part of a
cultural uh
moment exactly and and there are so many
examples of this i mean when i was
writing the book and i i mentioned
i i was i wrote over there's a chapter
in the book on council culture and i
thought shall i start listing the
examples and i
started collating them and there were
hundreds and i thought this is going to
go on forever so i won't do that what
i'll do is i just
i mentioned 10 or so in the footnotes
because i didn't want it to distract
because it's a given it's an absolute
given so the people who deny
cancer culture are usually its most
ardent practitioners and
i suppose they have a vested interest in
denying its existence um but i mean it's
indisputable i can give you some
examples if
you can't help give you know what's your
favorite example
of of a cancel culture moment well i
mean one of the first ones which
really got people thinking was the
cancellation of tim
hunt who's the nobel prize winning
biochemist who
uh he made a joke uh at a conference i
think it was in
south korea and it was deliberately
misrepresented by a journalist i mean
quite willfully misrepresented
that's clear um as being um as not being
a joke
in fact um and as being a simply uh
overtly misogynistic statement this
from a man who has done so much for for
women in sciences but you know that
wasn't taken into account
and by the time he got home from this uh
conference he had lost his uh
fellowship and his uh his reputation was
in tatters and this happened very very
very quickly
and of course in the old days what you
would do is you would uh if you if you
misunderstood
a joke or something that someone had
said in the conference you would perhaps
go up to that person and say oh now what
was that about that that worried me
whatever let's resolve this have a drink
and talk about it you know
not this kind of let's let's post
everything online and destroy this
person's career so
that was a really early example but
there'd been many many prominent ones i
mean there was the example of nick
buckley in in in
in the uk who's who is the founder
founder of a charity which sort of
focused on uh helping young people from
ethnic minority backgrounds out of
poverty
so this is someone who you would have
thought would have been uh you know the
social justice activists would have
absolutely adored and the intersectional
activists would have loved and yet
uh they they accused him of being racist
because he criticized
some of the aspects of the black lives
matter movement and and certainly some
of the um
stranger demands on their website which
i believe have since been taken off
uh and he and this man who has done so
much and devoted so much of his life and
work to helping people from ethnic
minority backgrounds
was smeared uh as a racist and and
another prominent example would have
been roger scrutin roger scrutin of
course one of the prominent conservative
thinkers in the uk uh who died
relatively recently
uh in 2019 he was supposed to be part of
this commission this government
commission to look into housing
and architecture uh and because he has
some very interesting ideas
about this and has written extensively
on it it was called the the building
beautiful commission
and um he was interviewed by a man
called george eaton from the new
statesman
uh and it was a an incredibly dishonest
interview that
not only did he misrepresent
representative in the interview it's
himself
uh eaton quoted him on his twitter feed
but took out key elements of the
sentences so in one case
scrutin had made a point which was
explicitly anti-racist
was explicitly critical of the the the
the chinese government and the way that
it you know
attacked its own people and made it look
like he was making a racist statement
you know uh he was talking about the way
in which the chinese government treat
its people like
robots you know like the inhuman and by
taking out the words it looked like
it looked like he was saying chinese
people are just like robots they're all
the same so it was the opposite of what
he had
and and that i'm afraid that kind of
boulderization cannot be i mean that
cannot be anything other than deliberate
so it didn't matter the truth did not
did not matter that's what happens when
a journalist becomes an activist
and but that wasn't the worst thing i
mean it's it's you know it's astonishing
that he
he kept his job after that but that
wasn't the worst thing about that kind
of misrepresentation the worst thing
uh was that the government immediately
kicked him off the commission yeah
what's going on
there because that's that's the second
part of this right i mean you have
people who feel empowered or emboldened
to just make [ __ ] up about people
oftentimes
or or bring something you know in the
worst possible light to
to make a point or to achieve some goal
but then
you know isn't isn't the real blame
there on the on the government committee
that says like okay scrutin you
you know we've known you for years we
don't think you're this but get the [ __ ]
out
yeah exactly that that's this is the
thing i'm always saying is that i feel
that the problem isn't the activist
themselves because there's not many of
them i know they're incredibly powerful
but the reason they're powerful is
because
uh those in authority continually
capitulate to their demands it happens
again and again time and again and this
is the problem
none of this would have mattered if if
nick buckley wasn't fired if
roger scrutin wasn't ditched from the
commission if tim hunt didn't lose his
fellowship
none of it would matter it would just be
people bleating on the internet which is
where what it should be
um so the problem really is that people
are just they don't have the guts
to stand up to these bullies and that's
the problem because it's an intimidatory
tactic that's why you only need
two or three uh people of this woke
mentality in
any industry or any corporation before
everyone capitulates because they are
terrifying people
i had um a conversation with a writer
friend and playwright friend of mine who
was working with one of these direct
a director who was an intersectionalist
woke activist style director and he said
that he started treating her like a a
dangerous dog
because if you said the wrong thing you
would they would go for you in this
vicious way and it
is that's unfortunately what's happening
let's uh you know somebody who
who uh spent some time in the barrel was
jk rowling
uh you know uh beloved uh you know
children's author
the creator of the harry potter series
she
um stepped in it in a discussion about
uh
trans rights and about uh you know kind
of biological essentialism for
lack of a better term she you know
she she got slammed she got attacked a
lot on twitter and elsewhere people rub
many columns against her
but you know uh practitioners of cancer
culture or supporters of
calling for truth you know just say look
jk rowling
you know she wasn't hurt at all by this
um
and in fact you know that this is just
discourse what's what's wrong with that
understanding
of cancer culture it's very naive if you
think that you are
to be continually bombarded day and day
out by rape threats death threats
threats of violence and misogynistic
abuse is not in any way hurtful simply
because you're a millionaire celebrity
shows a complete lack of understanding
of what it means to be human i would
have thought
um and that's a very very bizarre thing
what you the best
you could say is that she hasn't been
cancelled which is true you can't cancel
jk rowling
you can't cancel a multi-millionaire you
can't cancel the most successful author
in the world
you absolutely can't no publisher in
their right mind would ditcher
but they would ditch jillian phillip who
was the scottish author
who simply supported her on twitter yeah
she got ditched by by her publisher
overnight
because she's not as lucrative so so
this defense that well
because jk rowling hasn't been cancelled
that proves that cancer culture doesn't
exist
no it's the opposite it proves that it
exists but that it predominantly affects
those who are not the rich and powerful
it predominantly affects normal
people oh i was going to say but then
and then what do you what do you say
though
and i actually find this a compelling um
question i'm not sure that i agree with
the uh
with the answer but what's actually
going on is that because of the internet
and because of social media and a
variety of breakdowns of gatekeeper
institutions
um just in being able to control what
and where people talk but also
there's that kind of jellyfish uh
dimension that you're talking about
where you know authorities will no
longer actually step in to do the right
thing
um but you know that if what what we're
witnessing is this glorious age where
the rabble
finally has the ability to directly call
out and address
powerful people and it's not just people
like jk rowling about something about
trans rights but
you know in the united states um you
know uh
campaigns against i don't know you know
people like bill cosby
who you know got dragged on twitter and
ultimately was
canceled for a variety of sexual crimes
um you know that
you there is an ability now for the
common person to actually
interact publicly and directly with
people in power
and that that's what we're actually
witnessing um
you know that that the voiceless have
now been given a voice
and people in power don't like that the
voiceless aren't always right
i think the first thing to say is that
what you're describing there is a
creating the conditions for a witch-hunt
mentality
uh it's all very well saying that a lot
of good can be achieved by mass
mobilization online
and you could point to i don't know the
arab spring or whatever you want
depending on your
point of view and you could point to sex
criminals who are outed but there are
also lots of innocent people who are
accused of sex crimes
who are effectively tried via social
media that is not a good thing
actually um and i never take accusations
like that seriously in even if they are
overwhelming in numbers
because i know enough about history to
know that uh uh mass accusations can
often be false
uh and i think we shouldn't lose due
process but by the same token
it is a good thing like you say that
people are able to
to everyone's a broadcast that everyone
can get their opinion out there and
their
ideas out there that is a good thing but
that's not what we mean by council
culture
no one is saying that that you shouldn't
be able to criticize celebrities this is
this is a bizarre
uh misunderstanding you know actually i
think prince harry and meghan markle
may be saying that but yeah but they are
a law unto themselves aren't they you
know
yes they are absolutely saying that but
um no no one else is
uh no one is saying that the problem
with um
you know if people want to bombard
people on twitter people want to
criticize celebrities then you know i'm
all for that good
you should be able to criticize whoever
you want you should be able to be
abusive and insulting to whoever you
want
they don't have to listen to you they
should just block you and move on with
their lives you know i don't i don't i
and i don't approve of it by the way i
think civility is something we should
urge at all times
uh i don't take anyone seriously if
they're uncivil i will block them and
move on i'm absolutely not going to
waste my time
talking to someone who can't uh discuss
like an ad you know at one point uh you
i mean you have a doctorate in
renaissance poetry
um you uh you quote milton and obviously
milton and ariel pagettica has a
you know a very important and enduring
uh defense of an unlicensed
press or the idea that you should not
have
to put your thoughts through some kind
of
official you know mechanism for approval
before it sees print in the time in
milton's time there was a profusion of
tracts and the ability for for all sorts
of people
including very much anonymously to print
and publish whatever they thought
it's kind of a glorious thing can you
talk a little bit about how
cancel culture or what we're talking
about here
rather than celebrating the ability to
speak it's actually also seems to be
acting in the role of the government
sensor
that milton is pushing back almost
psychologically right because
it's not necessarily saying that the
government sensor is going to
pre-approve everything that gets
published but like we are
we're doing that work ourselves yeah
it's weird it's it's almost like people
are acting as government senses you know
and
this is one of the most curious aspects
of the social justice movement is
because it is an establishment movement
now
because you know it's absolutely the
establishment particularly in america
you've got biden
biden's administration is very much on
board with it
um but culturally speaking it's been in
the ascendancy and has been uh
the most powerful driving force in uk
culture even
even with the tory government in control
it doesn't really relate to this right
left debate
um and yet though that establishment
line is the very thing that activists
will seek
to maintain through their online
behavior uh so
this this is it's almost like you don't
need an inquisition
it's like the p the people are applying
the hot plates and the pincers to each
other by of their own accord well this
is it's foucault
right i mean that we've internalized the
panopticon essentially so we are you
know
we're we're doing the work for the
government or or for the power structure
we are
we are all participants yes we're all
the panopticon and it's interesting i do
think
uh foucault would have an awful lot to
say about the social justice ideology
and the way that it is
is it wields power i mean i mean i i
don't want to get dragged into
a side uh you know conversation on this
but he actually did push back against
that in his day
um it's just interesting to me that they
quote
or cite foucault as being this sort of
thing right they're luminary but of
course i think they've
largely misunderstood him right um you
know one of the
uh questions or one of the issues that
comes up and
you talk about it in the book is that
there is a huge gulf
between you know for lack of a better
term just crudely older generations and
younger generations when it comes to
a belief in the value of free speech uh
how
how old are you i'm 42. okay so you're
uh you know a late uh gen xer in an
american
ease yeah yeah exactly i'm on the cusp
um but
millennials and gen z in america you
know so people like basically 40 and
under
are you know polls and surveys show this
compared to older people like me i'm a
late boomer
gen x people are very much more in favor
of free speech it's just
we we grew up thinking that younger
people are much more
i don't know you know about this free
speech it needs to be balanced against
other concerns can you talk a little bit
about the gulf
in support for free speech and then
speak to why you know what happened what
happened that
free speech has gone from you know i i
in grad school i was taught by people
who were at the berkeley free speech
movement rallies
they were pushing you know even into the
80s and 90s they were like no everybody
should be allowed to talk
that's that's a given that world has
totally disappeared
yeah i'm i'm very wary and we should all
be always be very wary of just ending up
criticizing what the younger generation
do simply because they are younger and
uh there are a lot of things that the
younger generation have done which are
better
that a lot better than than the way
things were when when i was their age um
but i think you also have to point out
regression as and when it happens
and not be afraid to do so simply
because it is partly generational i mean
and actually this could all be redundant
anyway given that
the the signs very clearly are showing
that the the youngest generation
generation
zed are pushing back against the
millennial generation and
we will probably get a free speech fight
back from the very young
uh because a lot of them are very very
sick of it i'd say preponderance
actually
but nevertheless um yeah there is
something generational about it and i
think it is because
it is a coincidental with the rise of
identity politics and inevitably
we now have a substantial body of people
who who believe
um that certain fundamental liberties
are worth dispensing with
uh if if it can be said that they are um
effectively oppressing minority groups
unfortunately that analysis is incorrect
it isn't true so so uh it is people
buying into this uh this illusory
perception and
and just i mean i i'm very surprised i
remember giving a talk at a school where
i asked whether
uh there should be legal limits and what
and what comedians can joke about and
the fact that the majority of the
pupils put their hands up really through
me because i thought this is a very
is is the and you know as as we talked
about it more more it was very clear
that this hadn't been this wasn't a
thought through position this isn't a
position that they have been reasoned
into it is just the acceptable position
it's
the the high status opinion to have um
and you you know and so therefore i
think that is part of it i think it is
largely uh a product of my generation
more than anything i think my generation
are to blame more than anything because
it is
academics of my age and older who are
the ones who have instilled this this uh
this what we call that i suppose applied
post-modernism
is it the idea that speech is the
equivalent of violence is
that uh power you know everything is is
as seen in terms of power and that
that's reflected in language so
in order to disrupt power relations we
need to just we need to police and
regulate language
could you talk a little bit about that
yeah this is a
this this is a way you can fairly say
this is derived from fukodian thought
and
and and the the work of the french
post-modernist or post-structuralists
because you can say because if you if
you are convinced that our
our understanding of reality is entirely
constructed through language
uh therefore it makes sense doesn't it
that words
act like spells and incantations that
when they're out of the bottle they will
have this
uh effect on people and that people are
you know
it involves it it combines with that
post-modern idea this very
pessimistic view of humanity which
which is that we are we are malleable
and
that we are completely products of our
culture to the extent that we have no
agency
which is something that i don't get on
board with um and
and moreover and most importantly this
is why i
i wrote i wrote about it in the book is
that most importantly the the
the statistics and the research doesn't
support this view
so the idea that um we are just drones
who respond mechanically on cue to
language in movies the arts popular
culture the media it's been debunked
media effects theory has been debunked
over six decades of research so when we
say
oh it is dangerous to have a comedy show
where someone uses that phrase
because it will have this impact on
society and make society more racist
if you're going to make that proposition
let's have the evidence ha you know if
you have debunked
uh all of the six decades of research
into this
then show us your work let's see the
notes right
because i think it's just faith at the
moment it's just faith it's just
that's why the comparison with religion
works so well because it is not
something
you can't contest something if it is
simply asserted
uh without evidence this uh brings us
back to clockwork orange which you know
it's funny i i
think i'm going to go out and read
clockwork orange again it's been a while
but
the idea that you know we are what we
watch which i think actually comes
out of not out of post-structuralism but
a kind of frankfurt school
kind of understanding of popular culture
that we are
programmed by everything we watch and we
see so
donald duck donald duck takes his
punishment you know in the cartoon so
that workers take their punishment in
the workplace etc
um and it's fascinating in the 90s all
of this was debunked essentially and
there was a new generation of media
studies and cultural studies people were
like
no in fact we are end users like we
recreate meaning we crave meaning on our
own we don't care about authorial
intention whatever that might mean
but now we're back to the idea that if
somebody witnesses something they will
either model it
uh or it will have a drastic impact on
them
but you're right there's no evidence for
that
i'd say that that this pessimistic view
of humanity that i'm describing probably
does come
from the frankfurt school and it's
interesting to me that there are groups
people who want to resurrect
the worst aspects of of of that thinking
you know and and this almost very
snobbish
idea really that that that um the media
you know that popular culture i mean the
the way in which
the the the thinkers of the frankfurt
school completely dismissed popular
culture and divided it and and
and and and felt and i've seen elements
of it
in recent years i remember seeing noam
chomsky talking about how sports are a
form of mass
can control of the masses and this kind
of thing it's peculiar too
in in a in an age of social media where
things are kind of more individualized
or people are empowered to
consume what they want when they want to
produce things as well and engage
um yeah why do you think and this might
be beyond the purview of uh
of the book or um
or this conversation but why did
identity politics ri
arise as it did given that you know
the kind of institutional barriers to
all sorts of oppressed groups and
oppressed identities whether we're
talking about racial identities or
gender identities or sexual identities
these have all kind of faded in the past
20 years
it's not to say they don't still exist
but you know
england and america most countries are
less racist less sexist
less homophobic um more cosmopolitan and
kind of accepting
so where does why does identity politics
flourish
in that kind of setting i wish i knew
the answer i mean i've heard lots of
people speculate about this and you know
one potentially convincing uh
explanation is that there is something
alluring about being a victim
and once you've achieved equality where
do you go from there uh you know
you you start you start to i suppose you
have to start taking responsibility for
your failures and and
you know i mean it's to give the example
of stonewall which is the the leading
gay rights charity in the uk
i mean they won you know we had equal
age of consent laws we had
equal marriage we had equal hospital
visitation rights and
and legacy rights and all the rest of it
so we had complete
legal equality this is not to say that
homophobia was ever eliminated i don't
think it ever can be
actually although it's been greatly
reduced hugely reduced yes exactly
to the point where no one in their right
mind
even if they were homophobic would be
openly so because it would be you know
destroyed themselves socially you know
um
so they won and then i got and they get
to a point thinking well what can we do
now and i think a lot of people think
they took on the gender
ideology of of of extreme trans activism
as a as a
a means to keep themselves going because
by that point at the height of their
success
suddenly they had corporate support
suddenly they had uh money flowing
it's a very lucrative lucrative thing so
um
yeah maybe it's to do with the monetary
incentive maybe it's to do with power
you know maybe it's to do with having
some sway in society
i i do feel sorry though for for
activists who are convinced that we live
in the most oppressive
time that has ever been given that the
opposite is true
you know given that we have that we have
never there has never been a society
that is more
tolerant and open and progressive than
ours and less racist and less homophobic
and less sexist
not to say that none of those things
still exist i have to keep putting this
obvious caveat in
but to nonetheless genuinely see
fascists everywhere
seeing nazis in every shadow seeing
homophobes and sexism racism
that's your if you if you live in that
world of imaginary monsters it must be
absolutely horrible psychologically so i
do have some degree of pity
for people who who have bought into this
mass delusion i really do but it but but
the delusion is what it is
can you um you know many of the people
who are most vociferous and trying to
limit
speech whether through legal
restrictions or kind of cultural
imposition
are from you know very small uh minority
groups say
you know trans activists you mentioned
can you make the case to them
directly that they actually need
free speech more than anybody they'll
say you know there's too much free
speech and it's attacking me
but you're you argue i think pretty
persuasively that that's exactly wrong
that it's
the most marginalized people who benefit
the most from free speech
yeah and that you know the studies again
and again
show this um there's a human rights
campaigner called jacob i'm going to
pronounce his wrong his name wrong it's
um and he's done work into this and
looked into
uh the way in which the first thing that
a despot will do is clamp down on free
speech
and that that always has a negative
impact on minority groups
it always disproportionately affects
minority groups and and and you just
need to have a sort of
i suppose a cursory understanding of
history to know how this works
or you just have to look at uh minority
groups in
in islamic states and the way that they
are treated if you're a gay person or a
woman in
islamic states your life isn't you know
there are people who are
really risking their lives to try and do
something about that
um free speech uh is the first thing
that is to go
so in order to to to achieve the goals
that you
claim that you want to achieve you
absolutely have to protect that and i
think the problem is that what they what
they really mean is they want
free speech protections for themselves
but not for their detractors
but of course it's not a principle that
is uh
well i mean you dilute the principle
when you deny it to those that you
oppose
and i mean you may get to control the
microphone for a little bit
but inevitably you get pushed off the
stage right exactly the principle is
much bigger
yeah the principle is much much bigger
so you know one
very interesting kind of uh conundrum
here is
the uh who who is policing speech or
where where does speech happen
in the past and you write about this you
know it used to be tories in
england and you know conservatives in
america who were the ones who were
really trying to police speech a lot now
they
tend to be kind of more free speechy and
why not but more importantly
people talk about how it's not about
government censorship it's about
large social media companies facebook
twitter etc
and you write you know you you you say
that libertarians like me
you know libertarians in an american
context so we are using old arguments
when we say that facebook is a private
entity so they
get a right to basically run their
platform the way they want to
but at various and so you seem to be
arguing
on the one hand that they should be
treated more like a common carrier where
they don't get to pick and choose
they don't get to moderate the speech or
who gets to use those services
but then at other times that argument
kind of goes away and
it's clear like you don't want the
government to be in charge of regulating
facebook right so i i like how do you
how do you work your way through
all of that yeah i mean you might you
make it sound like i'm having a go at
you specifically
in the burkha you know i take things
very personal
it's the only way that i feel important
i should have written libertarians like
nick gillespie think this and it's
ridiculous what's he going on about
um yeah it's it is a difficult one um
but as the libertarian argument only
really works if it is possible to set up
competitive industries
as we saw with with um parlor that isn't
possible so if
it's back though i i hear what you're
saying no there's
this is a uh you know an absolute case
where
people liberals mostly who in other
contexts would tell business owners no
you have to do it my way
but then suddenly when you know
conservatives are like you have to let
us in they're like hey if you don't like
facebook
go build your own facebook yeah you know
and then they do
and then they're you know and then
people are like well we're not gonna
host it
we're not going to allow you to access
to our app stores we're not going to do
this
but parlor is back right it's bad but
it's not big is it it's not
i mean it's it's going to be incredibly
hard to break this deadlock it's going
to take a lot of
very very rich people and very very
determined people and
and readers right or users because it
might be that parlor is not
you know gab before it was an
alternative to twitter that's right it's
gonna
it's actually gonna be impossible
because when something like for gab is a
good example so when that started and
it's dedicated to free speech so
obviously
it's not going to boot off some really
horrible people
there will be horrible people there
joseph goebbels fan club is
right taking out all the good territory
they they got all the parts right by the
beach
but as soon as they're there right which
they will be right
inevitably because that's the downside
of free speeches you're going to hear
some horrible things right
but but once they're there then then the
activist press can say
can you know right cherry pick those i
can't say that's what this is a nazi
site right so then it's a loss
because then moderate normal moderate
people who don't like nazis
people like us are not going to go to
that platform by fear of guilt by
association it's all
very big but what do you do i mean on
facebook there are
vast mansions you know our father has
many mansions
with many rooms and there's still an
enormous amount of speech going on that
facebook frankly can't police um is it
so um i mean is are these legal remedies
or are they cultural remedies
how about we just have a situation where
we don't have an
exclusive group of publishers who are
not uh
uh responsible for the content of what
they publish i mean this is a weird
thing i mean
you know i don't i don't see why i can't
write a book
which just libels people left right and
center and not get away with it
well i mean the facebook twitter all the
rest of them are publishers they're not
platforms
they curate their material okay they're
quite quite explicit
that distinction is not important in
terms of uh
you know web interactive web services
such as social media websites
i mean reason for instance just to give
you uh you know
an example we have comments um
if we were liable for the content of
those comments
uh which are generated by the users we
would have no comments
um so the speech is you know would be
diminished if we
if we're following the rules that you
say that we should be responsible for
everything that appears on our website
but that's not quite what i'm saying
what i'm saying is uh we should perhaps
amend the communications decency act
so that it isn't so that maybe the
removal of uh
well i suppose it could be restricted it
could be it could be changed so that for
instance you are not responsible for
illegal content that is uploaded into
the comment sections of your
of your website that you fail to remove
i mean you might just not notice it for
instance or something like that
um but that you shouldn't therefore be
able to abuse that legislation
to just pick and choose what you remove
on the basis of that you don't agree
or that you find it offensive maybe that
would be the the way to do it i mean it
seems to me so there would be
no moderation so then you could have a
website where you would
you know facebook would have to let
every nazi on
uh and every nazi comment and i think if
it was restricted to if they had
if they removed illegal content if that
was
then that would be that would be fine by
me i have no problem with it i mean
personally i agree with you but i think
this
you know one of the problems and i don't
think people have
i don't think we've worked this through
because it's a relatively novel
situation but yeah yeah
moderation of content and regulation of
who's who's allowed on a service you
know do child molesters
uh not child molesters but people who
talk about the sexual you know
pure in a permanent way without ever
touching a child
are they you know should they be
guaranteed a free expression on
well facebook et cetera the the idea i
mean child pornography and child
molestation is illegal
so of course you can remove illegal
content you know this is what i'm
talking about
but i'm saying like the namlo you know
that north american man boy love
association talking about it
you know personally i think everybody
should be allowed to talk about whatever
they want pretty much wherever they want
well if you are if you want
if you want free speech then horrible
people are going to talk about horrible
things right but the difference
there's a clear distinction between that
and the actual uh dissemination of
illegal material like pornography
certainly and that is so that is
actionable i mean in the united states
stuff can be and defamatory comment you
can you can always if somebody calls you
a son of a [ __ ] in a facebook page you
can go after
the person you can't go after facebook
that's kind of worked pretty well well i
mean also i think there's
let's bring the agency back to the user
you know if it is a platform as
as facebook and twitter maintain look if
there's lots of people
talking about sick disgusting stuff
about uh sexuality or
or nazi stuff stuff that i just find
inherently uh
upsetting i'll just block those people i
do it all the time if someone comes on
my twitter feed and says something pro
nazi i just block them i do it straight
away and then i never have to hear from
them again
so so i don't need the people
in silicon valley to decide for me uh
where my limits lie and moreover
once you once you give them that power
then inevitably what happens is i now
can't look at accounts
of say gender-critical feminists because
they just don't happen to like their
opinions so they ditch them
i mean that's that's my point is i give
the power back to the individual user
everyone has a right to say what they
want but everyone has a right
to listen to what they want or not
listen as the case may be absolutely i
and i think you know this the idea of
empowering end users has kind of been
pushed to the
side instead of this kind of more basic
root level
discussion of whose speech should be
allowed on what platform
having said that i think moderation at
scale is just so
difficult yeah sure complicated and
we're still working
you know i'm actually i should say i do
feel in a sense it's
for the silicon valley tech giants
because there's a lot of pressure on
them from governments sure
to make to to moderate their sites and
all the rest of it as well as their own
employees right i mean
i mean that's it yeah you know and and
that becomes problematic but it's also
kind of
you know maybe a company is the sum of
its employees and whatever they can go
there well i sort of think when a group
of people at spotify for instance tried
to get
joe rogan's podcast censored or for
instance when uh penguin random house in
canada
that when they tried to get jordan
peterson's book back at that point i
think if you work for a publisher
and you don't accept that there's going
to be a range of views expressed in the
books that you publish you're probably
not actually
qualified to be a publisher and you
should probably be sacked no and and
that's not a cancel culture thing that's
like you're simply not qualified to do
the job it would be like me
saying that i want to be a professional
footballer no my complete indolence and
lack of physical fitness
does exclude me from that i agree and
it's uh this goes back to that question
of where
one of the things we're witnessing is
how hollow and weak
you know almost calcium deficient the
bones of our authorities are
uh where companies and governments get
pushed over i mean they're made of paper
mache
um which is both interesting and
liberating and empowering and quite
disturbing
so final uh question you cite mill and
others about
uh you know what in a more uh uh
contemporary context people like greg
lukianov of fire
um about that a um a broader culture of
free speech and thought is ultimately
more important than any of the actual
rules or laws that are written down what
are what are some ways that
what are some steps you think we should
take to get to
reviving a culture or strengthening a
culture of free speech and free thought
um you know apart from laws and things
like that because this really is kind of
you know it's it's a cultural phenomenon
that we're going through more than a
legal or political one per se
i think it's a really really good
question and i think my answer always
comes back to education i think it's
about
i mean obviously because i have a
background as a teacher as well i think
it's
it's about exposing young people to all
sorts of ideas
and um you know encouraging them to
think
critically and not to simply accept
things uncritically that would be my
approach to this i think it's very very
important in fact so
i it does disturb me the way that
activists have very much infiltrated
schools and
uh are very much um against the notion
of descent
uh we've seen in the uk recently
critical race theory making its way into
uk schools which makes no sense because
critical race theory doesn't make sense
in the uk context it's very much an
american thing
um but that has happened now i actually
think you should be able to teach kids
about critical race theory but i think
you should do so critically
i mean i think you should explain why it
is such a flawed uh idea and
and and that would be a wonderful thing
to do with because it is important at
the moment it's part of a national
discussion
so i think that should be the case but i
but i i think to teach
any faith-based position uncritically
in school is not a good thing uh you
know and and that's why
i say you know it does disturb me um
when i get into these stupid arguments
on twitter the the lack
of critical thinking that that to me is
is the thing that disturbs me most of
all
i i see these people i think you've
never ever questioned any of your own
views
it's never occurred to you that you
might be wrong uh and i think you know
teaching kids that uh we're always
likely to be wrong about something
just to just assume that it's it's a
great start
uh and and and don't just read a book
and think it's right you hear this
constant refrain of educate yourself you
know
and that people you know adequate actors
say why don't you educate it's not my
job to educate you educate yourself what
they mean by that
is read the books i the two or three
books i've read
and and accept them uncritically so
basically read ibra mexican read robin
d'angelo and just accept everything they
say well no because they're both shoddy
books
that's why we shouldn't do that we need
a redo of to sir with love right we need
to
embolden uh you know working-class
british kids to push back against 13. i
haven't actually seen to sir with love
from what i understand it's a kind of
precursor of dangerous minds
is that right yes very much so it's okay
it's uh it it has its own problems as a
teacher savior
movie but uh okay well we're gonna
appeal to me as an ex-teacher is so
uh a final question i mean you invented
titania mcgrath and you get to live in a
world where you know
after the nuclear holocaust or you know
environmental despoilation
the next civilization may well revere
titiana mcgrath
or to tonya mcgrath you know
unironically
is she having a moment or is is her time
you know is her time horizon limited now
are you optimistic or pessimistic
it's definitely limited i mean you know
i i i tweet very rarely from her account
now you know but but then because i'm
focused on something i mean like the
larger world view she represents
uh the problem is of course is is with
titanium i mean just at the point where
you know i i feel like i i've done
a lot of what i can do with that um it's
actually more relevant than it ever was
and that's the that's the really
annoying thing
so i will continue with i'll continue
with the live show for instance and
would
if i'm going to do anything more with
her it will be developing it out you
know i've done books and i've done the
tweets and i think that's great but
a live thing is is a really fun thing so
we're going to do some live shows in
september with with the character but
um you know i whether that idea i mean
this is the problem is that every time i
think
there's a bit of a pushback you know
something good happens and and and
that the activists don't win in a
particular fight you think oh there's a
pushback happening it's starting
and it never does it's it's just a
little glitch um
it's it's always regressing and and i
i think uh you know and it's b it's got
to the point where now
people like me who who espouse liberal
values
uh free speech equality etc that's quite
a controversial thing to a spouse now
that's weird i never thought that would
happen you know i'd never i never ever
thought that would happen so
um i don't know you know
i'm not a prophet i don't know when this
will all end i
i think it must though i think for if it
doesn't thank you
you've made a pretty good start with all
of your work but
especially your new book free speech and
why it matters andrew doyle thanks for
talking thank you very much
you